this is the first of four lectures that
will happen across
children's seminar how many students are
in the show
the Shulman seminar is one of two
seminars that are given each each year
sometimes each semester
Frankie seminar disease it's a parallel
program and these seminars are wonderful
because they know they are undergraduate
events under graduate seminars but they
bring in speakers from outside the
speakers a public lecture with you here
in the first up but they also they also
interact within a class session with the
seminar they go to dinner afterwards
downstairs a catered dinner with the
students in the seminars it's a
wonderful and perhaps exhausting
interaction with the students the pranky
seminar the other parallel program does
the same thing - Frankie seminars on any
topic in the in the humanities the
Truman seminar have a more specific
focus in this it is on a topic that
covers somewhere near the edges of
science and humanities it is named after
Robert Schulman Robert children
is Professor Emeritus and molecular
biophysics and biochemistry and the
world renowned expert in bio imaging and
I want to just recognize its presence
[Applause]
and remember he's an extraordinary man a
42-6 and across why reaches and he is a
founding member of the Humanities Center
all right that's all I have time to turn
it over to John Durham Peters who is the
instructor the Shulman seminar this
semester and he will introduce our
speaker thank you very much thank you
Gary Coleman thank you all for coming
it's a total delight to see so many
friends here dream of mine to see media
scholars flourishing at Yale so to see
someone who do Jason thanks very happy
it's also a great pleasure to introduce
my friend and colleague Paul Rodgers
professor of communication at Hebrew
University
he studied English at Cambridge with a
PhD at Hebrew University like many of us
he started in language and literature
it's a natural move into Media Studies
he's the author the image factory well
we do say that the general Marilyn
please so the image factory of 2003 book
about stock photography as we have media
witnessing co-editor of a book called
media witnessing and hot off the press
the poetics of digital media which he
recently discussed in class today I was
trying to think about how much our
friendship
what carbon footprint our friendship has
lost because we met a prong Helsinki
Jerusalem San Juan Boston and a new name
which I feel slightly I feel very guilty
about but also very happy that such a
person has crossed my path
Paul's exquisite at formal close reading
but also with larger ethical and
political questions and he's insistently
these two things need not be opposed
he's got amazing gifts at reading and
interpreting including in counter
intuitive ways read his piece on the
selfie if you want to have all your
expectations turned inside out
indeed his chapter in the recent book on
the selfie ends with the words poetic
justice many authors and media studies
see media as a struggle for recognition
and a fight to the death to speak with
to speak with Hegel Paul frosh I think
science with another thinker of the 18th
century and gives us Media Studies as a
Theory of Moral Sentiments please join
me in welcoming to Yale professor Paul
Tosh
[Applause]
good afternoon if five o'clock is really
is afternoon firstly I'd like to express
my gratitude to John Peters for his
hospitality as well as for his
intellectual and social generosity and
for inviting me to speak to you today
and also to speak to his students
earlier about my work I'd also really
like to thank the students earlier for
that discussion for their lively
challenging thought-provoking ideas and
comments and I've definitely got a lot
to think through as I fly back home my
breath my gratitude also goes to Bowen
for dealing with the logistics of my
visit and to the Whitney Center for
hosting this afternoon's event I should
also say it's very gratifying to me I
think it's the first time actually in my
career that I've spoken in a Center for
the Humanities which is unusual for
someone someone with a degree in English
literature from Cambridge but then I
flipped over to Communication Studies
and did an MA in communications and a
PhD in communications in a social
science department social science
faculty and the divisions even though
many of the working processes and ideas
crossed across moved across the the
faculty divisions quite easily the
bodies didn't follow across that move
quite so easily so it's really
gratifying to be
at a Center for the Humanities the theme
of this lecture series is elemental
media and in what fellows I hope to give
you my take on what a concern with
elemental media might involve I will do
so by presenting some arguments which
I've been developing for a while and
which you've recently been given some
expression in my book the poetics of
digital media and I'll also be taking
them somewhat tentatively in a slightly
new direction this is the first outing
for this new direction and I am grateful
for the opportunity to give it some kind
of shape though I will be the first to
admit that it still needs sharpening my
lecture is prompted by two main ideas or
one main idea and an observation the
first main idea is that media are poetic
forces by which I mean that they produce
and disclose worlds they are poetic
infrastructures populating our life
worlds with objects and beings to be
encountered including themselves and
they are also poetic performances making
available the worlds that they populate
and their own character as media for
recognition and reflection in moments of
conspicuous disclosure parenthetically I
should say that my use of poetics owes
more to to Jacobson's idea of the poetic
function of language as promoting the
sensuous palpability of signs and to a
Gambon's understanding of poesis as
revelation and disclosure of bringing
forth sometimes violently into presence
unless two approaches that emphasize
poetics as the study of the fundamental
principles by which representational
artifacts are constructed in the
contemporary era of mobile digital
devices and networks the poetic world
producing and well disclosing
characteristics of media have been
radically extended across social and
material contexts at micro meso and
macro scales of interaction and never
undergone intensification in their
intervention and embedding in the
spatial and temporal conditions of both
ordinary and extraordinary human life
they have become a second nature our
media technologies are so thoroughly
into woven into the fabric of everyday
experience and into the multi-sensory
sensory motor and kinesthetic habits and
rhythms of our bodies
to the degree that they are fundamental
frameworks for living and in extreme
situations basic equipment for staying
alive while the metaphor of second
nature was applied by Walter Benjamin
and others to pre digital technologies
the near omnipresent permeation of
mobile and ambient digital devices into
the smallest crevices of our everyday
spaces times actions and interactions a
permeation that also links those
crevices to global communication orders
make the attribution of second nature
and the very character of that second
nature both quantitatively and
qualitatively distinctive from the
analog era calling technological media
second nature
clearly casts them in elemental terms as
a techno culture which appears as a kind
of nature as a human being man Y
affected artifice that is nevertheless
an environment which we experience if
not as primordial
there is a given meal for our existence
and to which we have adapted and are
still adapting our bodies and minds the
paradox of the phrase second nature in
this instant is not simply that
artificial humanely made culture comes
in the guise of nature or that it
competes with nature but it even then it
can never be purely nature as such the
quotation marks around the term should
not be removed since as John Peter says
nature is always nature through culture
to us this then is the first idea
digital media as a poetic second nature
producing and disclosing our hyper
mediated life worlds I will expand on
this idea in a moment and it will form
the bulk of the talk the second idea or
probably observation is that if digital
media are experienced in elemental terms
our second nature
then perhaps we can learn something
important about their elemental status
by attending to key metaphors that are
applied to them in public and scholarly
discourse the metaphor I wish to explore
briefly is saturation a metaphor of
infiltration and permeation to the point
of fullness or even of excess though
also of other things such as absorbency
plenitude and intensity which is
frequently used to describe the sheer
ubiquity of media
knowledge ease I will suggest that this
metaphor simultaneously uses the image
of a natural force principally liquid to
cast digital media as an anti
environment drenching and drowning an
inhospitable to human life
notwithstanding the vessel the vessels
we have used to traverse it and
therefore not naturally fitted to human
ends or dimensions while at the same
time and unlike some other aqueous
metaphors with which it is associated
enabling a consideration of media as
powerful poetic condensers intensifiers
and vessels of human and more than human
existence
hence the deliberate ambiguity of the
title of this talk the saturation of
media can be taken to mean that media
saturate the world or that they are
saturated by the world thereby giving us
new kinds of access to it so to return
to the first idea I'll get rid of this
quite muddy thing you look at this this
image is just a screen saver it's not
relevant to anything
well it's quite poetic possibly I don't
know but anyway it's just sort of
photographer it's Philip look at the
course yeah okay back to the talk so to
return to the first idea that media
produced and disclosed worlds that there
are poetic infrastructures and poetic
performances to begin with I should
briefly indicate that I'm employing the
idea hardly knew that our conditions of
existence as human beings coalesce in
experience through the formation of
worlds the principle world is out of our
ongoing everyday shared sense eight
living in relationships
what phenomenal phenomenological
approaches have termed with varying
definitions the life world the world is
already given though dynamically so to
into subjective experience and which pre
structures all systemic or deliberate
attempts to analyze or explore aspects
of existence other worlds which overlap
with the life world and can extend from
and into it include perceptual and
symbolic worlds which are overtly
imagined such as fiction and those which
are beyond the possibilities of direct
perception
but which are presented or inferred as
actual eg the microscopic entities and
environments and macroscopic
Astrophysical systems which science
visualizes as well as the cosmologies of
mythic and religious cultures worlds are
imbued with ontological density and
complexity they are understood to be
populated by beings and objects but are
not reducible to those being and objects
which in turn are not reducible to the
media or symbol systems by which they
are perceived worlds possess a capacious
nough sit enables a sense of dwelling
within them the world that we the
inhabitants of the post-industrial
global north experience is given as our
primary habitat is as I've suggested
thoroughly technologized while the
ability to create shape and disclose
worlds is a characteristic of
technological media broadly conceived
across historical periods the poetics of
contemporary media are different in
degree if not also in kind from the
context that preceded them among other
things we habitually depend on media for
constant unnoticed reassurance that the
world out there exists this reassurance
is provided both by the continual
arrival of the representations of the
larger world and our habitual
unremarkable exposure to media signs of
their own smooth functioning as
connective systems such as the tiny
symbols on our computer and smartphone
interfaces indicating connection to
wireless internet or cellular networks
indicators that I will argue and not
simply technical indicators of
sufficient functioning but actual signs
of life itself or vital signs following
but we might we might call these
perceptually marginal yet operationally
perpetual indications of smooth
functioning the rustle of media the
barely noticed background sound of happy
machines the noise of what is working
well more to the point media
constructing disclosed worlds much of
whose content is media themselves media
observed themselves make themselves the
object of attention and discourse as a
culturally constructive second nature
imbricated but in everyday existence the
idea that media have become ever more
deeply embedded an in fact intertwined
with our lives in the world to the point
that they constant
a techno cultural environment which is
increasingly difficult to disentangle
from a set of primary putatively direct
or unmediated situations is a key theme
of debates in communication and media
studies around what is often called the
mediation of everything or the concept
of mediate ization one concept that I
have found useful in this discussion is
called rien heps a metaphor of what they
call the medium manifold Corddry in hemp
used the manifold metaphor because in
topology according to them it describes
the adequate representation of multiple
dimensions in a form of fewer dimensions
for them this is analogous to the
situation tip of typical social actors
in rich countries for whom on the one
hand the possibilities of communication
and information resources are almost
infinite this is certain and who but who
on the other hand are usually only
presented with a reduced set of
communicative options in everyday life
Corddry and hip I should note are mainly
interested in implications of this
production for social order and
political power however this idea of the
medium manifold is also significant for
a poetics of media it allows us to think
about how media make world's present
within and already mediated world life
world how does the experiential
givenness of the life world in and
through media operate across these two
levels of the media manifold the reduced
and the potential how is the expansively
mediated life world given presence
within the small worlds of users which
themselves are part of the imagined
totality of media possibilities that the
term manifold includes to use a slightly
different terminology how our
contemporary media worlds implicated in
relations of imminence media devices
practices objects texts embedded in our
everyday life worlds and transcendence
our life world's extended beyond the
everyday horizons through media devices
practices objects and texts we can
describe media's poetic relations as
manifold in two complimentary ways first
media to the poetic world of world
presencing and world disclosure by
multiplying folding worlds within other
worlds hence manifold they embed worlds
within one
and populate our private and shared
spaces with individuals and objects from
other worlds making them imminent to
everyday experience while at the same
time enabling the extension and
transcendence of experiential boundaries
this infolding can strangely warp the
relationship between macrocosm and
microcosm and between interior and
exterior as i will go on to show a
little later on such multiple in
foldings of worlds within worlds is a
fundamental attribute of the everyday
largely overlooked work of media as
poetic infrastructures hence the second
poetic process associated with the
manifold is to make manifest those in
folded worlds and the very processes of
embedding and populating that media
routinely implement through acts of
disclosure and performances of unfolding
broadly speaking then media operate in a
double relation to the life world and
its multifarious extensions and foldings
and in corporations media shaped their
ongoing largely taken for granted modes
of being present by virtue of their
connective perceptual and symbolic
attributes and they make their modes of
presence perceivable available for
recognition and reflexive exploration in
occasionally extreme moments of over
recognition media thus involved in
constructing the experience or givenness
of existentially intertwined worlds and
of enabling their ever relevant their
revelation through representation and
tangibility the given world is given
through media probably the best way to
clarify and elaborate everything that I
have said so far is by offering a close
reading of a particular media text I'm
now going to show it also provide a bit
of light relief I'm now going to show a
very short video only three and a half
minutes long it's part of a series made
by Disney of their own movies called
as told by emoji and all of these movies
are available on YouTube in this series
Disney retells they're classic films as
though they are occurring on a
smartphone with the principal characters
played by emojis communicating with one
another via various mobile interfaces
and applications so we are now going to
watch Beauty and the Beast as told by
emoji I hope you're familiar with the
story
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay I have quality laughing so
hopefully you enjoyed that bit that's
the end of the jokes okay so it of
course easy to dismiss this video as
unserious mere entertainment flim-flam
designed to further enhance and promote
that promote the Disney brand and its
products and I know none of that I would
deny well I would actually deny that
it's unserious
but I wouldn't deny that it's designed
to promote Disney's products but I also
think it's worth treating it as a highly
intelligent and very succinctly on
contemporary media culture I think that
it's an extraordinarily rich text which
makes visible in concentrated form key
attributes of the world producing a
world disclosing character digital media
but I've already described and also of
the way media are unfolded into and also
fall across our lives let's unpack this
by moving across the text somatically
the first theme concerns the population
the populating and production of worlds
the video presents mobile screens as
world populated by emojis emojis which
we have mainly become familiar with
through text-based digital communication
are depicted as pictographic symbols
through which characters actions
emotions spaces and times are embodied
and expressed they are also presented
here as animated entities who can travel
traverse diverse device applications
moving in and out of games videos and
different screen interfaces they're
depicted as transmedia beings and they
seem to be at home everywhere on the
screen understood as an environment
however one of the first questions a
narrative analysis of the video would
raise is who is speaking here drawing on
Goffman's tripartite typology of speaker
roles we could designate the Disney
Corporation as what he calls the
principle the party responsible for
reducing the message also following off
when it makes sense to designate the
videos a credited production team in the
role he calls author in that they have
created the script and designed the
content of the film
now this role could also be Co assigned
to the
any corporation it is less clear who is
position for viewers as the one telling
them the story enunciate in the
utterance of course the video itself the
video title itself provides a possible
answer to the question of who this
annunciator might be as told by emoji
the ambiguity of the construction by
emoji potentially meaning either told
via emojis as a pictographic symbol
system or told by an entity called emoji
very serendipitously given the status of
the video is an animated text this inand
enunciate of a narration and narration
function is called by Goffman the
animator emoji is not is therefore not
just an animated form but a potential
animating narrative agent a collective
personage who begins the video in the
pre credits shot with the sequence of
pulsating dots in a speech bubble
signifying someone is typing followed by
a text that declares once upon a time as
a possible annunciator an animator of
the entire video text then emojis take
on a creative and expressive life of
their own not only moving within and
across the various applications and
interfaces represented within the device
world of the smartphone but also taking
us out and outside the frame of the
mobile device to show it to us from the
outside the video populates a smartphone
world but also potentially other worlds
that overlap with and in frame the
smartphone with a new quasi autonomous
animate being the second theme concerns
the presentation of the screen world as
a seemingly enclosed system that
parallels both the fairy tale story
world and the digitized social life
worlds of viewers the film's humor is
based largely on the provision of
parodic digital equivalents to Zion
ethic elements in the fairy tale the
equivalent for space is a vertically
oriented screen of the smartphone which
it is worth noting also constitutes a
gravitational field the rose petal falls
downwards time is represented by the
chronological ordering of speech bubbles
from top to bottom which is the usual
direction of scrolling
social media apps but also by the
already mentioned pulsating dots
indicating Bo that time is passing and
that something is about to be said or
appear for instance each wolf in the
chase sequence is preceded by these dots
other equivalents are more obvious and
even funnier the castle has a property
offered for rental on Airbnb the castle
library as a digital archive of virtual
shelves model long Apple books where
only the titles shown just happened to
be Disney films the magic mirror as an
app called enchanted mirror time which
is based on Apple's FaceTime the roar of
the beast as a sound file spent spelled
are a WR and later welp the battle
between the beast and the angry
villagers as a version of the game Angry
Birds all of these equivalents in
addition to their humorous effects
create analogies between smartphone
technologies and the enchanted world of
fairy tale this frequently makes the
enchantment banal the magic mirror is
FaceTime is my particular favorite but
it also makes manifest the capacities of
media as forms of world enchantment in
particular their possibilities for
enabling action at a distance
often figured in older literary works as
the prerogative of magic perhaps a
crucial point is that while the media
has a clear parodic dimension and both
at the fairy tale world and the
smartphone world
they're very conjunction and analogy
discloses a smartphone world as an
environment whose defining
characteristic is that it is replete
with a vast range of overt mediating
possibilities some of which like media
technologies in the past assume the
guise of magic additionally and perhaps
even more importantly the amusing
incongruity of apps such as Airbnb and
FaceTime featuring in the fairy tale
narrative appear not just as background
elements but as drivers of plot and
action
drawing attention to the broader social
and existential agency of the
applications depicted it reminds us that
the smartphone world is not self
enclosed at all that it is not confined
to the device but is radically
distributed across and embedded within
physical and social sites in the
extended life world of users
the third theme is an extension of the
second the video presents his world has
embedded in and if folded within other
worlds occasionally in ways that
strangely walk microcosm and macrocosm
internal and external legend in life the
smartphone screen is the ground of
virtually all of the action and the
video begins with a close-up of the
bottom of the screen so that no one said
that one cannot see its edges much of
the video is filmed in this fashion the
edges of the video frame are either
coextensive width or narrower than the
screen of the depicted smartphone
however there are important moments when
we are shown the smartphone in its
entirety facing the viewer standing
upright on a wooden table covered with
old-style leather-bound books in a
fairytale landscape of forests mountains
and a castle this miss onsen of the
videos in framing world suggests that
the smartphone itself exists within an
overarching world of Legend and folktale
and is ready for use by a larger
full-sized non emoji beauty or beast in
fact it suggested it is the world of
beauty and beast the movie which in a
frames and contains a smartphone a
smartphone which is now as we watch
telling the story of beauty the Beast
the movie in miniaturized
emoji form to complicate matters in
addition to this implication that the
movie Beauty and the Beast is the videos
broadest in framing world a segment of
the original movie the dance sequence in
the ballroom actually appears at one
stage on the smartphone and the emojis
of buting the beasts jump into it and
begin to dance this implication and
extraction of worlds beyond worlds of
the movie world as a container of the
device world of the story along with the
movie as a world unfolded within the
smartphone world that it contains again
makes visible a powerful characteristic
of contemporary digital existence this
is the complex multiple and folding of
worlds within other worlds in intense
into permeation at multiple scales of
social and physical life a
characteristic that I mentioned earlier
under the rubric of the media manifold
if we add one more potential layer to
this manifold an actual viewer such as
me
or you watching the movie on the screen
of their smartphone we can appreciate
even further how deeply
multi-dimensional the manifold can
become and how cleverly it can be made
manifest for us through media themselves
the last theme I want to note is perhaps
the most striking of all this is the
rendering of life itself and of its
transformation as a media function
earlier I briefly mentioned the idea of
vital signs that in a society where
mobile digital devices and networks have
created a default condition of Perpetual
contact ability indicators of media
functioning have also taken on new media
new meanings and urgency as signs of
life the video shows this metaphorically
and we can of course build here on the
older idea of animation not simply as a
technical cinematic process but as the
imbuing of spirit and soul to seemingly
inert matter the metaphor is clearest in
the equivalence between battery life and
organic life brilliantly encapsulated by
the use of the Rose as an interface icon
displaying the smartphones remaining
power the life of the Beast is identical
to the life of the device and its world
the second instantiation of this theme
is in the final resurrection of the
beast as an upgrade in the operating
system again completely identifying the
life of the character with the life of
the world he inhabits and drawing a
parallel between the magical
transformative power of love and the
transformative power of technology
given the parodic tenor of tenor of much
of the video I interpret this
equivalents as being at the expense of
the assessment and aggressive promotion
of pseudo novelty and upgrades by
software corporations and its attendant
called cultural condition in when the
Chung's words of upgrading to remain the
same the resemblance to the Apple logo
an Apple iOS update screen seems to make
Apple the butt of this joke but again
beyond the critical potential in a video
made by Disney there is also an
important point about digital existence
revealed by this equivalents sometimes
battery
life is equivalent to life itself for
instance if you need to be rescued from
imminent danger and the use of the road
is a battery life indicator if the
dramatized dramatization of a digitized
vertical sign we should perhaps then
replace the hyphen between the words
battery and life with an equal sign
battery equals life in my book I give an
example of the last whatsapp messages
sent by a worried mother to her soldier
daughter who it alert obtains that turns
out could not respond because she was no
longer alive the whatsapp interface
showed the non receipt of the messages
and the absence of the daughter from the
application on the mother's screen but
we all know situations where we have not
heard from our loved ones our partners
or our children and we text and phone to
no avail and also cannot tell when they
were last seen as the wording goes on
whatsapp this is the vital sign we are
wait waiting for a sign that is vital in
that it indicates life but it is also
vital in a way that our organs are vital
are crucial to our psychological if
there are physical existence again this
existential nervousness about the non
responsiveness of others is not new to
digital times sitting by a landline
phone I don't know how many of you
remember those waiting for it to ring
simply to know if a loved one were safe
performed a characteristic anxiety or
pre-digital on modernity and it is
probably true to say that our
disconnection anxieties move as far and
as fast as our connective technologies
themselves will take us what is
different however is that today our
connectivity is near constant a default
setting of our lives as many teachers
and lecturers know from their classrooms
and integral to that setting is the fact
that we almost always carry these
devices around with us including to
private spaces such as a bathroom they
are close to our bodies frequently in
direct sensuously experience contact
with clothing or skin the absence or
presence of vital signs is us an
embodied and multi sensuous experience
registered not just through interruptive
notifications on our screens but by
sound vibrations in the air
and tactile physical vibrations against
our bodies our disposition of possible
alertness to such science is not simply
a matter of conscious expectation but
what an actual bodily adjustment and
configuration not just the constant
fidgeting with our computers and
smartphones which many of us find
difficult not to perform in their
presence but even the experience of
phantom vibration syndrome where we
imagine vibrations and other alerts from
our phones which have not occurred our
digital devices now provide perhaps
impose is a more appropriate word what
we could call constant connectivity at
the level of the hair-trigger and the
nerve ending in these circumstances
whether one or one's beloved has battery
life becomes an existential concern to
still to the most minut sensations of
our bodies as air could as they're
continually achieved to an
all-enveloping media manifold I have
used this close reading of the video to
elaborate and concretize ideas about
media as well producing and world
disclosing forces particularly in
conditions of hyper mediation where
media are experienced as second nature I
want now to briefly ask a further
question if media are experienced in
such an elemental fashion as to seem
like nature what can be learned from the
use of elemental metaphors to describe
them in popular and academic discourse
this interest follows directly on for my
explication of the poetics of digital
media in two ways first because it
understands metaphor as a force for
traversing and mutually in full
unfolding worlds as a mode of world
making and of world disclosure and
second because by emphasizing poetics as
a mode of disclosure it takes issue with
one of the chord and a mental metaphors
you often use to describe the
environmental dimensions of media the
key image I'm referring to was as John
Peters points out popularized by McLuhan
but did not originate with him that the
fish cannot experience water as its
environment because it has no anti
environment with which to contrast it
and therefore perceive it as water
however one of the things that our
elemental and other metaphors for media
do along with the rich reflexive
it's like the one we've just seen is
make visible and palpable the
environmental dimensions of media in
part from foregrounding incongruities
and also potential hostilities our use
of metaphors and images enables us to
imagine and experience media as if they
were an anti environment the term
saturation is one of a family of many
semi aqueous metaphors applied to our
contemporary media environment our
society we are frequently told is
saturated by media in general or by
cameras or by screens or by images nick
quaderi
usually a very considered theorist has
even expanded on this rhetoric somehow
finding the term saturation insufficient
we live he says in an age where everyday
life has become supersaturated with
media flows in short a cynic could claim
that the metaphors saturation has
definitely reached saturation point this
use of saturation which I admit I may
have employed myself in the past
accompanies a series of other watery
epithets the flood of images the deluge
of texts even according to Todd Gitlin
the torrent of media most recently I've
been reading on photography sites about
the tsunami of images on social media it
is of course not meaning media abundance
it is signaled by these terms but their
overwhelming force the biblical
pretentiousness of their cat Islamic
cactus cataclysmic proportions and their
hostility to human existence as a
physical creature principally adapted to
life on land usually when employing
these metaphors the speaker is
principally describing and is mainly
describing the sheer ubiquity of media
technologies and media artifacts turning
this quantitative pervasiveness into a
qualitative threat by suggesting that
media as a watery element with title
with tidal force will quite simply drown
us saturation however while definitely
associated with these more apocalyptic
terms and certainly youth frequently as
a synonym for media ubiquity is
nevertheless subtly but significantly
different to give to begin with the
etymology of the verb saturate does not
begin with water orally
quit or with being overwhelmed but
according to the Oxford English
Dictionary with the Latin satyr RA which
means full or satiated the earliest
meanings of the word in English retain
and emphasize this sense where to be
saturated means to have reached the
state of satisfaction and fullness a
state perhaps teetering on the border of
excess but not there yet
only one of the six main different
meaning meanings offered by the Oxford
English Dictionary refers to the state
of being soaked or thoroughly
impregnated and many of the metaphorical
examples given are positive such as
quote having one's mind saturated by the
Gospels in fact the examples in which
saturation clear is clearly used to
denote an overwhelming and excessive
presence or force come only from the two
most modern usages both on the 1940s and
50s one is the economic saturation of
markets by a surfeit of products the
other is saturation bombing given these
meanings I would venture to say that
saturation is actually very interesting
and useful way to think about media as
elemental as long as we pay attention to
its metaphorical fecundity and semantic
range this is because it invites us to
think seriously about what meat might be
the appropriate boundary states to a
mediated environment what I mean by the
boundary States is how we answer the
question what and when is too much media
what is a surfeit of media and how does
a simple on experience
if we accept with many other thinkers
that humans are characterized by
adaptability to their environment and
that we co-evolved with the technology
as we produce it is likely that our
boundary States may be reasonably
perhaps radically fed flexible no doubt
up to a particular physical and
neurological limitations for instance
while we decry shifts in attention and
in attentiveness seemingly caused by
contemporary media and a culture of
distraction shifts that some see as
detrimental to the intellectual powers
of the whole generation of youth that
culture is also continually producing
cognitively demanding and intensely
immersive experience with which people
of all ages engage just look at the
Renaissance in this contemporary
television drama for instance as well as
extremely rich short forms such as the
emoji video we saw earlier
under estates also visible according to
domains of action and power we may
accept an even welcome media saturation
in its sense of fullness or satisfaction
in the increasing availability of a much
wider range of cultural objects and
experiences online than ever before but
we may feel that the point of saturation
has been well past in the presence and
activity of media that gather and
distribute information about us to
others without our awareness or consent
and saturation is a useful metaphor not
for simple media ubiquity but for the
complex boundary work required in our
experiential cultural and political
relation and political relations where
the presence of media across more and
more contexts of our life worlds
additionally and perhaps more poetically
saturation is useful for thinking what
might constitute the material sensory
and symbolic substance of a mediated
environment what I mean by this is at
the metaphor of saturation as pervading
and permeating that a point of fullness
suggests something of the novel
interstitial character of contemporary
digital media I use the term
interstitial because like the liquid the
saturates a piece of cloth media have
come to occupy new spaces and new
temporalities both in everyday
experience and in social structures that
were previously unable to occupy or
unable to occupy quite as extensively
this occurs on the level of everyday
temporal experience were live into
personal conversation and representation
at a distance can now be performed
consecutively with other tasks such as
sitting in a lecture or watching
television indeed where television can
now be watched anywhere in at any time
and the same applies to video Latour
famously asked where are the missing
masses arguing that objects have been
ignored by sociology as accents filling
dimensions of social relations space and
time I would argue the media in
particular I become pre-eminently good
at filling social dimensions that were
previously thought to be relatively
empty this idea of interstitials of
interstitial saturation also applies in
a technical and perceptual or sensory
sense our bodies are increasingly
occupied with media than in the past
they fill perhaps
saturate our ears with sound through
headphones they fill our eyes with
increasingly fine-grain images on
screens with ever higher resolutions
faster refresh rates and sharper colors
and they occupy our hands at speeds and
with operative gestures click swipe
press stretch scroll type that are
performed with astonishing dexterity
well at least by some of us the again
the question of how our world is
saturated in its substance is made
available for reflection in media itself
as it's a question of to what extent the
substances and boundaries of our lives
should be opened up at all scales from
the macro scrub from the macro
structural to the micro sensory to the
technologies that both populate our
lives and disclose our conditions of
existence there are two final points to
make the saturation is not simply a
metaphor for ubiquity but also for
intensity the basis for this metaphor is
not liquid but color and light in
technical terms the saturation of a
color refers to its light intensity
using few wavelengths of light produces
more intense and saturated color
applying this metaphor in relation to
media advised us to think less about how
media saturate our world but about how
they might be saturated by the world
how can a medium be saturated by the
world first it must be receptive to the
world as a kind of rest vessel or
receptacle open to the registration of
the world's plenitude and unexpectedness
much of media use is instrumental and
highly formalized pre anticipating how
the world should be represented or
communicated in particular ways and no
medium can be infinitely open to the
vagaries and fullness of experience yet
some uses of some media suggest
possibilities whereby receptiveness of
saturation can be achieved most
obviously this is a case with
photography with serious mate with
theorists making claims that in the
words of Cal Silverman photography is
the world's primary way of demonstrating
to us that it exists and that it will
forever exceed us this notion of media
as a receptacle for saturation is
complicated by
the claim again in photography theory
that the image returns its receptivity
to us in the form of an intensity a
sharp poignant punctuating concentrated
return of the real which Bart calls the
punctum so two forms of saturation can
be thought in relation to media as
saturated by the world receptivity and
intensity along with the potential
richness of saturation as interstitial
and adaptive involvement in the world I
would venture to say that this
metaphorical thinking about media
enables us as cultural scholars to make
ourselves full perhaps to the point of
excess and receptive to media hopefully
our discourse will enable to return some
of media's potential intensities to our
publics thank you very much
[Applause]
yeah
but just because of stress which is
[Music]
right it may very well be for some
people I haven't really thought about
mindfulness and I don't know a lot about
it as a either an intellectual or social
or moral movement and it is well no one
is really mindful to generalize greatly
their argumentative and their plenty of
other things but I'm not sure that I
mean no that's not true there is a you
know there's a lot of mindfulness in
certain areas but it does strike me that
your question is about an attempt to
mindfulness does not use media it
attempts to move away from media and
engagement with media as far as as far
as I can tell from what you just said
sorry well that's what I was going to
ask you because I mean for example I
just give you another example it doesn't
strike me as mindfulness but there is a
lot of there are cameras on YouTube or
videos which are based around repeated
sensory and sensory motor features where
the content and in particular for
example this ASMR where people make
gentle scraping noises on other kinds of
noises into microphones which has a kind
of sambal say hypnotic other would say
in irritating effect on viewers but the
point of the video is to generate a a
kind of um I supposed to use another
very trendy word effects which responds
which allows one I suppose to move above
or beyond
other forms of sensory engagement with
media by virtue of engaging with the
videos themselves so that's the only
thing the closest I can get to answering
the question in terms of mindfulness I'm
I mean it does strike me also possibly
as a movement a reaction and they were
in the history of media they've been
constant reactions against the spread
and increasing intensification of media
from a whole variety of social groups
whether that's through emphasizing
personal bodily modes of producing
dispositions which was this media -
simply unplugging media or refusing
you're actually right I'm not the first
thing that is done by Orthodox and
ultra-orthodox people as soon as the
Sabbath goes out they turn on their
phones it's the first thing the first
there's one there are two lights which
which which commemorate which indicate
the end of the Sabbath the first light
is the candle of the second light is a
cell phone in other words that's not
about mindful that there is a certain
mindfulness away you know enabled but
the intensity of anticipation for that
connectivity and for our thoughts people
is very limited connectivity because
they only use what they're known as
kosher phones it's quite phenomenal so
so I'd be interested to see whether
there isn't a kind of similar dialectic
with mindfulness that you do your
mindfulness exercises and then you go
back on Facebook but I don't know
it's totally contingent yeah yeah it's
totally determine nother thing anyone
necessarily planned it and I don't think
that was that necessarily I don't think
it's a necessary progression from from
less to more saturating media what are
the historical forces that produce it
well the infrastructures for wireless
for wireless communication and there are
lots along the way there were lots of
decisions that aren't obvious you know
so infrastructures for wireless
communication miniaturization there are
a whole lot of forces creating the
possibilities for this for this kind of
saturation and there are also you know
limiting factors and at some point we
may find out that the although I don't
address environmental issues that the
environment is going to be an
availability of certain kinds of of
metals and other resources to use in
these infrastructures it's going to be
limiting factor on how they develop so
is it looks directly you start to
contingent absolutely is it new
I think it is qualitatively and
quantitatively new for the reasons I've
given you could understand it has
historically connected to or continuing
certain kinds of development there were
long commentated on in in earlier eras
of modernity the the increasing
nervousness of modern life the
increasing alertness of certain
institutional centers know the newsroom
as a center of social alertness which in
which you know also extends to for
example the emergency room or the police
center or the or the military room
increasing centers which have which
increasing areas of the political and
social infrastructure which have to
continually monitor and respond to as
quickly as possible
emerging developments
in society at large what's interesting
is that that has now devolved
increasingly onto the individual as well
both our senses of these greater
institutions so as I said to the
students before we have become
journalists embedded potentially in our
own lives through mobile devices and
through the actual physical embodied
relations we have with these media
technologies which demand a kind of
embodied disposition or physical poise
of alertness we read we use our
computers and we scroll through our
mobile devices as though constantly
ready for the next operation that we can
perform and we're constantly interrupted
on those devices by other messages
telling us about new things that we can
and should perform we're constantly made
into nodes for receiving and passing on
information francesco kai said has
written wonderfully about how the
screens themselves have become like bus
stations to a certain degree with
information and images passing across
the moor through them and those screens
are on our persons and as I said before
their screens which are also multi
sensuously connected to us and ready to
alert us whether it's my wife in trouble
or the fact that I need to update the
operating system and I can't initially
tell the difference between those
different kinds of vibrations so I think
that is qualitatively different but but
it wasn't necessarily ever going they're
always going to be that way and it
doesn't mean by the way that there won't
be movements like mindfulness increasing
controls imposed among other people by
by governments and states to control
media use bankruptcies or the fall of
great media giants all of these things
are possible so it's not necessarily
going to become more saturated but we
have and the other thing about
saturation of course is at this point
it's always on the point of of being
saturations about fullness not
necessarily about excess and that
fullness is relative it can shift
historically
contingently so what my generation may
experience as a surfeit as to much as
INXS my children my experiences as
replete as full as enabling and
empowering of the time worrying and
different approach to media because
[Music]
basically if I think today it's on one
side the fullness of the shelves in a
mall or the moral choice I have to do
between ABC that are all choices maybe
good
so the multi folder may be exactly more
things I can enjoy or a choice I'm
called to do may you you're wrote a
fantastic text on the moral choice and
moral responsibility and is one of your
college major equally better the way in
which the multi folder today may be one
thing or the other
anyway about the multi
fooled I recommend you the last
spider-man spider - yeah exactly the
question enjoyment is where I yeah and
this is a yeah so okay so um well this
is a really important a difficult
question and I don't think there's a
simple answer I think that there is a
historical challenge posed by our
digital devices and what we've called
the multi fold or manifold and that is
that there were they enable
possibilities which in the past were not
there so it is the case that while I am
on Amazon shopping
virtually in the mall through my Amazon
app I can also be making moral choices
about whether I should be signing on
loan online positions or petitions
whether I should be forwarding
distressing news to other people whether
I should be resisting or or publicizing
private information I have somehow
acquired to those with whom I'm
connected and also whether I should
disconnect publicly and very clearly
from people with whom I violently
disagree all of those choices have been
made available by this new media
manifold in other words and they've been
available on a very intimate and
perpetual basis there is no end to the
number of things I can buy an Amazon if
I want to given the money and there was
also no end to the number of online
position petitions I could probably sign
and as as quickly as I sign one petition
or forward one video another one will
emerge for me to engage with so it
actually means that the question of I
wrote a piece one time in the beginning
of my book starts off with the idea of
pre digital media producing a moral
environment of indifference which is
morally enabling we do not have to
engage with the other I don't think
that's true in the same way with digital
media I think that we constantly faced
with the choice of do i or do I not
forward swipe search and what else am i
doing at the
same time precisely and the criticism
that it's slacktivism gets the point but
gets it point wrong slacktivism
criticizes online petitions etc because
it says in part they do not involve
enough effort that's precisely the moral
challenge that I see because they do not
involve effort we can do them efforts
effortlessly which means that we should
be doing them as frequently and as often
as possible and then how do you make
those choices so that that's putting the
manifold terms
response organization whereby the next
generation could look at replete nurse
could feel repeat whereas we feel super
abundant or suggest a deeper disorients
in historicism that could it could be
recursive yeah you know the history of
Technology and in a sense the history of
median ization of the world in Regan in
response to an itch is at least ten
times and partly uh probably a lot
longer than ten times as old as the
species Homo sapiens in the first place
so I'm wondering yes the condition is
different now but the condition is every
different is always expressed as always
experienced as different but it is
always about niche construction and it
is always about immediate eyes niche
construction as long as there has been a
technologized relationship to to the
environment I'm wondering whether there
is a theorization in your in your work
that can encompass that distance or
whether the theorization really is
localized in
you know a moment the last hundred years
or whatever so what even in niche
construction I mean the fact that we as
organisms are busy are busy building our
environment and always have been busy
the other environment the environment
changes as we change and the environment
then in a feedback way as is changing us
that in that building of the environment
has always been a technological one as
long as many issues has existed and it
has that technology has been changing in
its in precisely in its media relations
to to to place this in relation to the
world and so where does the theoretical
distinctive theoretical distinction on
here I would work with people like
accord you in their in their argument
and they argue basically there was a big
historical distinction been made and
they didn't just talk about last hundred
years they were talking in spans of
millions of thousands of people they're
certainly cookie about said are good no
good said one at least since it since
the invention of printed not before and
their argument is that the intense into
current interconnectedness of
contemporary social economic political
and cultural life enabled and perhaps
imposed by contemporary media is not
simply a matter of quantitative increase
it makes a qualitative difference it
imposes loads and judgments and
possibilities Amyx and possibilities
which did not previously exist it
exposes to view forms of social
organization which previously did exist
but they weren't viewable and they're
very visibility itself makes a
difference classic example is friendship
okay now it may be the case that
Facebook calling every one of its
contacts friends in itself won't make a
big difference but it could be again
well time will tell I mean you're
absolutely right this is a blink of an
eye in terms of in longer hits intently
longer historical perspectives it may be
that the visibility of the people I know
and the people they know and the people
they know to one another and the fact
that we can check the people we know and
the people that they know in relation to
one another before making a commitment
does change a basic for social
interaction and that would be for
example one of their arguments and I
would subscribe to that that it is
possible to say that this is not simply
a matter of quantitative increase which
will recursively create a form of
adaptation there was an actual
significant qualitative change going on
there to which we may add that we may
become more calculative we may become we
may react and become more mindful and
say we're having nothing to do with it
but it but it is a qualitative change so
whether that's a quantitative change
across the whole history of the human
species well I would think you to say it
probably is I think it's certainly a
qualitative change if we if we think
about the last five hundred years so yes
what I mean by that we'll all feel it or
we'll all be able to dispute it but but
it's already become a term of discourse
I don't know you guys are students and I
don't know how John of Francesco Arliss
Givens I constantly get there safe from
students and I've read academics and all
said the public press and talk about in
our media-saturated age and it's become
almost a dead metaphor in a way and what
I'm trying to do it here I suppose is to
reanimate it or revitalize it so I think
there is a sense that I mean again part
of it is is we do have to worry this
draws on the previous question you do
have to be a little bit concerned about
present ISM which is the idea that
everything now is different and
everything now is new and I said there
were certainly great continuities both
with previous media would preach
previous historical and cultural
formations but there is clearly concern
about that we are in a period of surfeit
and I think that thinking about that the
idea of saturation can take us away from
worrying merely about surfeit and
thinking about what the shape of the
interaction between media and ourselves
and our social frameworks could be
that's why I talked about this
interstitial relationship but but anyway
so so so it's not simply subjective
it's a discursive framework for thinking
about media and culture today yeah so
I'm wondering how like I feel like
someone who grew up when smartphone were
still yeah
so I've been kind of distinguished
between the virtual world and the like
my life world how do you feel like the
generation that grew up you know in the
midst of that will just really make that
distinction or is the virtual world for
them just as like elemental people who
are younger than you yeah because you
look really young to me well I think I
mean I think we all have to take into
account the increasing somatization of
the distinction between both increasing
the continued continual somatization of
the distinction between virtual and real
within within popular culture
so I think that firstly I in terms of
cultural discourse and cultural forms
the questions of what is real what is
mediated what is relationship between a
real animated what is a rigid relation
which in my life and what I what I what
I see or read on various media it's
constantly raised within media
themselves whether it's popular
entertainment or whether it's articles
or or programs or controversies and
scandals so that's the first time I'm
not sure that that that that younger
people I don't know how old you are but
let's say 16 or 17 year olds wouldn't
would would would not be aware of that
distinction and and I listen you know
again the advantages of being old is it
Ireland but my mother telling me not to
jump out of the window like Superman
okay because I couldn't fly and where
was I going to see Superman on
television there's a long history of I
mean we talked about it in class before
media panics and also iconoclastic
approaches to certain kinds of visual
media which suggests that they are going
to be the route of certain kinds of
fantasy or evil where people can't tell
the difference between the real and and
the other sorry
Don Quixote I mean exactly so it's it's
it it's not a new concern I think I mean
there is an argument for by some
academics that the certain media which
in certain context for example
photography were treated as evidential
have now as a matter of course that your
first response to a photograph was to
think it is evidence and then possibly
to suspect it that then has now been
reversed that given the proliferation of
digital media technologies which we can
all use sorry sorry exactly
so no but but that's become prevalent
that the argument is now that the
prevalent approach to photography to
photographs is that they are to be
suspected first and only once proven by
the way this was for a long time the the
approach of the locals of course was
that they were not to be taken at face
value but the but they are to be
suspected first and then only taken at
face value if they can be in some way
reinforced what's interesting about that
I talked about this in the book is that
a lot of the innocence I suppose
institutionally and rhetorically created
about photographs has been transparent
transferred to a particular kind of
digital object which we call the screen
shot which is often used as evidence in
digital during this not in all digital
areas but certainly in journalism you
all know Trump's tweets through
screenshots and no one has ever thought
that they may have been manipulated but
their digital images are easily
manipulable in other words the
screenshot has inherited approaches to
it that come from an earlier era
possibly of photography so but the two
aunts go back to your question the
virtuality reality think it's not new
and I and it it's continually raised
within media I mean I can think of a
dozen films not doesn't but a handful
films certainly also from the last few
years we talked about it and anyone
watching black mirror you know so you
know what I'm talking about it's it's
you know they do it better than scholars
frankly we should resign it become my
soul mate
the radicalization language no I'm
stumped by that actually I don't know
where to think about language in
relation to into in relation to the kind
of questions of connectivity that I was
talking about at the beginning of the
book
signifying oh oh oh yes okay so okay so
if I thought we were talked about in
relation to that the opening example
denied oh no there's a lot of really
interesting stuff going on about
language and I'm not particularly a
researcher of digital language itself
but there's you know that this firstly
the return of a pictographic form is
phenomenally interesting for any kind of
language scholar and the and the feeling
out that's something that I haven't
talked about but the feeling out of
emote emojis that come from a number of
different sources but one of those
sources were emoticons
so emoticons if anyone remembers you
know the old pre-windows and even after
that you know texting and web they were
formed because you had a small number of
C Mon symbolic Kathy symbolic characters
and they were formed by you know by
doing the the brackets and the and you'd
put the colon with C eyes and you put a
- it's a nose and then you get a smiley
face and that's one of the sources for
emojis and you'd have to do that while
you were typing to express emotion so
language so and so the emoji themselves
flesh out and fill out that initial
quite schematic use of writing and in
that sense it's very interesting as I
said it's a return of a pictographic
form the other thing is that I think I'm
not sure quite what to talk what to say
about about about language itself is the
is the prime is the strained
relationship between the conversation
and the archive that now occurs again
I'm not so much talking about spoken
language I'm talking about writing
writing texts emails as well but mainly
texts has is a is increasingly a
conversational form is is devised for
simplicity concision conciseness
quite often directness humour
responsiveness there's all sorts of
issues about turn-taking in conversation
in conversations which are written which
are very very interesting and again new
norms have to develop for that but it's
also an archive in other words it
doesn't disappear in the way the
vocalize language does unless recorded
so it produces possibilities both for
revisiting conversations which occurred
in the past and also for reinserting
older conversations into new ones both
for good and for bad that again has
impact on cultural memory among other
things it also has an impact on the
relationship between the past and and
current discourse for I mean we talked
about this briefly in the class I mean
you know the the the the the ability to
remind someone that they said someone
hurtful to you something hurtful to you
in a previous text is an unintended
consequence with impact for social
relations of the textual form that we
would call texting or whatsapp and also
and also an email so I don't think I've
really answered your question but
there's clearly some interesting
challenges going on in the mediation of
language in particular writing spoken
the spoken form I'm not expert enough to
say anything because anything I think in
lumen 80 on that but anyway I took a
long time saying
comments what does I've seen YouTube
videos that say the electromagnetic flux
from these digital devices I can chew
contributing significantly to the
exponential growth of chronic disease
right entirely but significantly and the
other thing is oh yeah of course
any medium can be corrupted but but you
know and and you know many of the claims
made against Facebook around the last
election here and also around frenzied
in the UK are about about precisely
about that and you know there are there
are some people with whom I would not
always agree who would say that any
medium operating in a capitalist system
is inherently corrupt anyway so but I'm
not sure that I would necessarily agree
that but there is but there is
definitely any medium can we know the
print can be corrupted I mean you know
what is mine counts upon other than a
corruption among other things of writing
and publishing you know it's many other
things as well but it is that - so and
to go and your first question well I
don't know and that's one of the dangers
we're living with and that could be I
mean to go back to a question of
historical contingency we could all stop
using mobile phones if someone proves
unequivocally a connection between these
technologies and certain you know
certain diseases if that can be proved
unequivocally and that there is no we
could see restrictions on their use for
children restrictions on their use for
other populations and perhaps
restrictive than they use altogether so
either legally imposed or voluntarily
adapted so while I can't speak for what
you see on YouTube and there's plenty of
stuff that's out there that's untrue and
rubbish but just because you're paranoid
it doesn't mean that they're not out to
get you if you tell it that means so so
who says it may be true and and you know
and that's again a question for historic
origin contingency like the question of
resources we may run out of the
resources decree to carry on to carry on
with these developing these
infrastructures or they may prove to -
physically harmful to us in ways that
you know printed texts weren't for
example
last last question yes a stranger with
me about my [ __ ] but a what video games
oh okay just like we keep up like I feel
like that's almost like common spaces
where like world building and yeah
mostly rule like discovering is yeah
experience and also like increasingly I
got a brother it's not just like a game
with other kind of social so again so I
can you know this isn't I mean I
mentioned television in what it might at
the end about about about thinking about
about saturation and I mentioned the
Renaissance of television video games
are phenomenally powerful way of
reimagining both well for example that
there are number of questions that
interests me to do with video games the
first one is connected to this idea of
the object of of the mobile phone which
is embodied connection to a particular
kind of interface and a lot of the work
for this was done first by scholars of
of video games so we're very interested
in what does it mean to be connected to
an interface of ayran interactive
joystick which allows all sorts of
interactions that the mouse and the
trackpad and even the touchscreen can
only dream of being able to provide
including forces forces forms of
feedback etc so that sense of embodied
interaction with a created world is
something that I think that video games
have developed to an extraordinary
degree I'm not a games player but I've
seen their immersive a narrative
potential and what's very interesting
there is that for some media theorists
immersion and explicit interactivity was
sometimes understood to be a
contradiction so that the more immersed
you were in a film or a book the less
conscious you were of it as a medium now
that seems to be conquered
by many of the game systems they're very
successful
they enable immersion and full
concentration while at the same time
requiring awareness of the medium as a
medium which can be manipulated which
can be altered in which you can take
multiple views and in which at the same
time you can also engage in
conversations with other players at a
meta level about what you are doing so
they've challenged and they're an
example of a very good object to think
with because they've challenged some
previous assumptions about how forms of
engagement with particular kinds of
media can and should work based on the
part in the past on separations between
modes of looking through media and modes
of looking at them and here they seem to
work together in new combinations which
are very which are very culturally
interesting you know ascetic
[Applause]
[Music]